that's the one see I wasn't a big Santa
tour with my buddy Adam Devine right
workaholics pitch-perfect mono family
super famous dude never travel with a
real famous buddy before understand some
of the perks that you get to experience
okay second night Nashville he goes hey
you guys want to go to a Kings of Leon
concert I know some of the guys the bed
we can get free tickets hang out dude
that's because of where you're at that's
your level of Fame I would love to go to
a King Julien concert you know and
afterwards if you guys want some free
broccoli cheddar soup I got a buddy who
manages a Panera not too far from here
so I can bring you the table it's not a
free concert but it's free soon don't be
an [ __ ]
no Simon free my buddies buddy is
working maybe we could get half off so
we have to pray for this one I drink a
bottle of patron I've never done that
before a bottle by myself I think we've
all had these moments you're feeling
good you're rested before you head out
you look in the mirror you're like it's
no worries from every aspect of this
evening get to the green room
all right well the keys to Leon are
hanging out there's snacks there's booze
I'm sure you're like me man if you're
hammered and you haven't eaten for a
while you get a very apocalyptic mindset
about foods I'm in this green room I've
been eating for a while doing the band
comes in sees me doing this try some
pickle out of the situation applause
that bird he's like hey man leave some
for the rest of us now and instead of
acknowledging his attempt to build some
rapport just go and keep shoveling Jolly
Ranchers like Finders Keepers man fire
your own strawberry rectangles
cut to Courtyard Marriott Nashville okay
I'm hammered I'm home I'm presented with
the with the snack lime so these hotels
offer up which it just grocery store
leftovers Lean Cuisines we're looking
breed hoes and on this particular night
three lonely cans of Chef Boyardee beef
Aronian yeah judging by your reaction
you guys like oh cool I don't even know
they were still making that [ __ ] yeah
they are and it's about time you start
giving some respect to one of the most
prolific Italian chefs of our generation
I take three cans up to mushroom all
right I'm pumped I put three cans in one
bowl one bowl it's not a quick to hold I
have a can a Beefaroni I'm not thinking
about the consequences I'm pumped up I'm
singing dancing from the microwave
pumped about the delicious Italian
cuisine I'm about to slam I'm singing
songs I'm like I'm about to eat me man
ready oh [ __ ]
I put in the microwave for nine and a
half minutes I didn't realize that's way
too long man I take it out I start
walking over to my pen I trip over my
suitcase [ __ ] lights on beside Busey
confidence
who's the confidence makes you think
outside the box like that we've all been
there do my best friend on New Year's is
smashed here so hammer at the end of the
night you try to open the front of his
apartment by pressing his iPhone on the
door that's busy confidence you drank so
much tequila
you thought he came home to the future
that's a lot of [ __ ] what and normal
after that type of behavior but he's
Asian so I was like that's not totally
impossible for you you can do that it's
not far off
Asians are don't moving well ahead of
the times technologically speaking so
when you see an Asian to try to open a
door by pressing your phone on it we're
all standing behind them like are you
hiding from us tube over the bed
Beefaroni everywhere all right all over
the end of the bed now most do this more
like cool man
you went to bed you clean up the mess
you got a good night's sleep start your
day the next morning like a decent
normal human being yeah or I slept
around the [ __ ] Beefaroni [ __ ]
all right you would too I was [ __ ] up
don't judge me I picked up two noodles
put them on my mouth pressed my arms
like a vampire I was like do that world
I see in the morning not concerned get
it call from the front desk 8:30 this
off now service in the boys tried this
was mr. ray how you feeling you okay
they go yeah man I was eating Jolly
wrenches with rock stars last night what
have you done is all right you're coming
in hot
I'm excited man still drunk right then
he goes I'm glad you're doing okay
because the make blood all over your
bedsheets swear to god I'm gonna have
drunk half this rage today this is new
information me
who kicked me to blend up my bed [ __ ]
now you didn't offer that in the help
then I figure out what was up and I
literally say oh no no no
Beefaroni sheets and then there's this
silence on the other end of the phone
with good reason oh yeah you can't just
say no no Beefaroni sheets and expect
anybody to understand what the [ __ ]
you're talking about what I think we're
just gonna go up Avery sheets that's
every Tuesday yeah thank you will you
with the keys early on of [ __ ] when I
always set this up the guys like I'm
glad you're doing okay I go first sure
man thanks for the concern I think the
bigger question though is what's going
on in the heads of your maids when they
can't differentiate between chunky pasta
sauce and a possible crime scene dude
where are you training these ghosts just
come in take one look at the bed go mad
and walk out of the room and I can try
to taste one of the meats where's this
how I know I hit rock bottom he goes
that's probably something we should look
at you I appreciate the heads-up but mr.
right before you check out I'm gonna
need you to pay for that beaver army he
goes we have your own security cam
coming into the courtyard at 3 in the
morning
grabbing three cans of beef aronia off
the shelf fist pumping to yourself and
tripping into the other
like [ __ ] you either that's how I roll
clearly you've never had fever Oni
before because I was